welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and we've got to
talk about the possibility of namor's
longtime rival atuma joining the mcu's
villain lineup in wakanda forever rumor
has it that he and neymar will appear in
black panther too so today i'm going to
break down everything you need to know
about atuma and speculate on how his
updated character design might be
incorporated into the mcu fans have been
speculating for several years now that
prince neymar of atlantis and his
underwater crew would show up in the
film and the mcu has been teasing his
eventual appearance for over a decade
now in iron man 2 and that can be seen
in the background showing markers on and
off the coast of the african continent
the dot in africa is obviously wakanda
but the one in the ocean has to be name
wars under the sea kingdom of atlantis
also when questioned about what's going
on with the underwater earthquakes off
the coast of wakanda and endgame okoye
says that their people are dealing with
it by not dealing with it was it
possible that she was being
intentionally vague to downplay any
conflict the wakandans might be having
with the atlanteans it seems likely
according to a recent leak of concept
art from black panther wakanda forever
actor to know cuerta will play the role
of the submariner and additional images
show shuri akoye nomura and atuma
interestingly both neymar and atuma are
decked out in aztec influenced attire as
opposed to their traditional costumes
from the comics suggesting that marvel
may be leaning away from their atlantean
comic story line likely to avoid any
similarities with dc's aquaman if the
mcu does decide to introduce the aztec
pantheon we may even see yet another
realm of the afterlife the talalocon
knowing that namor's longtime rival
atuma will be a part of wakanda forever
provides a layer of grey that we might
see explored within the film all reports
indicate that namor will be the primary
villain of the movie but comic fans know
that this anti-hero has played on the
side of the avengers from time to time
so we might see the makings of a
redemption story in his character arc
similar to how the first black panther
focused on an internal fight for the
wakandan throne neymour's position of
leadership might not be uncontested and
atuma could be seeking to oust him but
who exactly is atuma this aquatic
warlord first appeared in 1961's
fantastic 433 as the name was oceanic
nemesis but his full backstory was fully
explained in the 2000s in 2011's fear
itself the worthy number six we learned
that a tumor comes from the scara tribe
a group of homo mermanus beings exiled
long ago from atlantis a long-standing
prophecy among their people proclaimed
that a warrior from this tribe would one
day conquer atlantis by force and that
prediction eventually came true with the
birth of a tuma born on the battlefield
of a war between the scara tribe and
their enemy rorack atuma survives but
sadly his mother dies in the process
he's discovered clutching a blood clot
that he ripped from his mom's heart with
his sticky little baby hands and rorack
thinks this is so badass in metal that
he immediately starts believing the
prophecy to be about a tumor roraq
enslaves the women and children of the
scar tribe but atuma thrives in spite of
rorak's control growing strong enough to
lead a revolt against his captor and
subsequently dedicates his life to
taking down namor and atlantis achuma is
clearly a formidable force like all
atlanteans atula can see in pitch black
darkness and his other senses work
underwater with pinpoint clarity he has
incredible strength speed agility and
durability which at one point is
enhanced by doctor doom to match namor
skills in hopes of convincing him to
take down their common enemy together
etuma's signature weapon is a
three-pronged sword but at one point in
the comics he also got a hold of an
asgardian hammer it's unlikely that
we'll get a thor connection in wakanda
forever but it's too kick-ass not to
mention in 2020's king and black name
war series we see atuma and neymar
briefly allied in their teenage years as
the scara tribe tries to mend political
fences with the atlanteans teaming up
with the swift tides to fight oceanic
baddies unfortunately atuma's father
along with the rest of the chasm people
are killed and etuma swears vengeance
against the atlanteans for ostracizing
their people this is what sets up the
events of the comics in the 60s and
onwards which tells stories across six
decades that mostly end in atuma's
failure to defeat neymar and conquer
atlantis despite his powerful army and
ruthless fighting in 2012's avengers
versus x-men number seven neymar
destroyed wakanda with a tidal wave
ending a brief ally ship with t'challa
in the wettest most horrible way
possible because of this conflict the
atlantean empire was also weakened this
prompted atuma to reach out to neymar
offering to join forces with him restore
atlantis to its former glory and defeat
the wakandans once and for all although
atuma and namor became buddies at
certain points in the comics i think
that they're gonna go a different route
in wakanda forever borrowing from both
black panther number 21 and squadron
supreme number 12 i think we're going to
eventually see a begrudging allyship
form not between atuma and namor against
wakanda but between namor and wakanda
against atuma perhaps mirroring t'challa
and killmonger's conflict from the first
film amore might see that the bloodlust
that atuma has against the surface world
will only perpetuate a cycle of violence
and that feasible solutions might be a
better path forward with t'challa's
passing this could present a chance for
his successors to resolve conflict with
diplomacy and prove their merit as the
new leader of wakanda if atuma is played
as a foil to naymore the warrior might
refuse any form of peace and opt for the
aquatic equivalent of scorched earth we
might also see atuma receiving some sort
of edge against neymar from a mystery
benefactor a mystery benefactor later
revealed to be doctor doom echoing their
team up from the comics and branching
the story of wakanda forever into the
larger tapestry of phase four and beyond
we did just get a fantastic four tease
with reid richards and the multiverse of
madness after all so we know doom is a
coming if a tuma does end up being a
secret villain in wakanda forever it'll
likely take neymar the wakandans and
iron heart to stop atuma from taking
over the surface world follow me on
instagram and twitter whitneypuppy
follow new rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you